[Music]  these two brilliantly colored monkeys  are the pride of their native country  brazil  this is the golden lion tamarin  [Music]  the golden lion tamarind signature  feature is its silky reddish gold coat  its long mane frames its bare face thus  the feline namesake  these little guys love to eat fruits  insects and small invertebrates and  they'll use their long thin fingers to  hunt for their prey in narrow spaces  they spend their lives swinging in the  trees of brazil's southeastern coastal  forests  in the 1970s only a couple hundred were  left in the wild due to collection for  the pet trade and habitat loss while  still endangered today conservation  efforts around the world have boosted  their population  the golden lion tamarin has become a  national symbol in brazil even appearing  on the country's money  this is the golden lion tamarind  [Music]  you